Ist es okay?
Okay.
Schönen Abend.
Karakulak ist mein Name und ich bin der Diensthabender Arzt auf diese Station
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschrieb führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Okay. Bevor wir über Ihre Aktele beschwerden, schieb ich hin, möchte ich ein paar Fragen
zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Svetlana Lewandowski.
Frau Lewandowski, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vorunachnahme bestabilen?
Ja, Svetlana schreibt sich S-V-E-T-L-A-N-A, Svetlana.
Ja. Lewandowski, L-E-W-A-N-D-O-W-S-K-I, Lewandowski.
Okay, Frau Lewandowski, wie alt sind Sie?
41 Jahre.
41. Und wann sind Sie genervt geboren?
Am 14. Juni 1983.
82.
Okay. Und wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 74.
74. Und wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
69 Kilo.
69. Also, Frau Lewandowski, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, was wir beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich komme heute, weil ich seit zwei Tagen starke Bauchschmerzen habe,
die in den letzten Stunden auch noch schlimmer geworden sind.
Und das macht mir große Sorgen.
Ja, ich verstehe, Frau Lewandowski, könnten Sie bitte genau beschreiben, wo die Schmerzen sind?
Ja, die sind links vom Bauchnabel auf der linken Seite, mehr so im mittleren und unteren Bauch.
Sie sehen so bis rüber zum Beckenknochen in der Gegend zwischen Bauchnabel und Beckenknochen.
Beckenknochen.
Auf der linken Seite.
Und am Anfang waren die nicht so stark, aber jetzt sind sie ziemlich stark geworden.
Und wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Auch eine Schmerzkala, wobei ein sehr leichter und sehr starker Schmerzen bedeutet?
Ich würde sagen im Augenblick bei 6.
6. Okay. Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen aushalten oder soll ich Ihnen etwas geben?
Nein, ich kann sie im Augenblick noch aushalten.
Es wird jetzt nicht so lange dauern.
Ja, okay. Nein, nein, das dauert nur 20 Minuten ungefähr.
Okay.
Und bitte könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben, sind Sie eher dumpf, drückend oder stehend?
Also sind mehr dumpf und bohrend wie ein Bohrer.
Und es ist dauernd, der Schmerz ist dauernd dauernd.
Okay. Strahlende Schmerzen, irgendwo hinaus?
Nein. Nein.
Und sind die Schmerzen löstlich aufgetreten oder langsam?
Langsam aufgetreten.
Langsam. Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Übelkeit oder müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Also mir ist übel, schon seit einigen Stunden ist mir übel, aber ich habe bisher noch nicht erbrochen.
Haben Sie viel bar, Frau Lewandowski?
Ja, ich habe Fieber, ich habe gemessen 38,5.
Okay, haben Sie dagegen etwas angenommen?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie seit zwei Tagen diese Beschwerden haben.
Waren Sie schon mal deswegen beim Haushalts?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich, wenn es nicht besser würde, wäre ich vielleicht morgen oder übermorgen zum Hausarzt gegangen.
Aber jetzt sind die so schlimm geworden.
Da habe ich gesagt, jetzt muss ich nicht.
Sie haben gut gemacht, Frau Lewandowski.
Haben Sie auch Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme beim Stuhlgang.
Da habe ich gemerkt, seit ich die Bauchschmerzen habe, habe ich keinen Stuhlgang gehabt bisher.
Sonst habe ich regelmäßig jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Ich habe allerdings auch seitdem ich die Bauchschmerzen habe, wenig gegessen, weil ich keinen Appetit habe.
Oh, okay.
Und wegen Schmerzen können Sie auch nicht gut schlafen, oder?
Die letzten beiden Nächte waren nicht gut.
Sonst kann ich gut schlafen, aber die letzten beiden Nächte waren nicht gut.
Mhm.
Verstehe.
Okay, Frau Lewandowski.
Haben Sie auch, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihr Hautfarbe gelblich gewollt ist, oder?
Nein.
An der Haut ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Sauaustürzen oder Sortbrinnen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay, Blechungen haben Sie?
Ja, aber wenig.
Das ist nicht besonders.
Nicht besonders.
Okay.
Hatten Sie schon mal ähnlich erwischt werden?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, ist einmal.
Ja, verstehe.
Und sind Ihre Beschwerden nach dem Essen aufgetreten, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das kann ich nicht sagen, ob das mit dem Essen zu tun hatte.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es mit dem Essen zu tun hatte.
Nein.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen gewandert oder ist es immer gleich?
Nein, sie sind ziemlich in der Gegend geblieben, wo sie auch aufgetreten sind.
Okay.
Als sich nicht viel verändert.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihnen, der Krankenfolge, die Frage Lewandowski.
Also ich wollte noch sagen, gestern Abend habe ich versucht, mit einer Wärmflasche
den Bauch zu behandeln, die Schmerzen, das ist aber dann schlimmer geworden durch die Wärme.
Okay.
Kann auch nicht auf dem Bauch liegen, das tut zu weh, das drückt zu sehr.
Haben Sie auch etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen linden?
Wenn ich vielleicht auf dem Rücken liege und die Knie etwas anziehe, das ist vielleicht
etwas leichter, aber nicht wesentlich.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Ja, vorallem Lewandowski, jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer Krankenfolgeschichte.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche kröntische Erkrankungen bekannt, wie zum Beispiel
die Zuckerkrankheit oder die Blutkrankung?
Ich habe seit der Kindheit einen Diabetes, einen Zucker, muss ich seit der Kindheit
Insulin spritzen.
Ich habe jetzt aber die ganzen Unterlagen in der Aufregung vergessen zu Hause, die
ganzen Medikamente, die ganzen Insulinpräparate und das Spritzschema, aber mein Mann bringt
das hinterher, der zeigt Ihnen das gleich.
Okay, sind Ihre Blutzucker gut eingestellt?
Ja, bisher war das immer ganz gut.
Er habe ja 1c-Wert, damit waren die Ärzte zufrieden, ich gehe regelmäßig zu Hausärztin und auch
zum Diabetologen und bisher war das eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Ach super, okay.
Noch weitere Krankheiten haben Sie?
Ja, ich trage einen Herzschrittmacher.
Seit 10 Jahren, da bin ich zweimal kollabiert und man hat festgestellt, dass mein
Herz-Erregungszentrum dieser Sinusknoten und diese Überleitung gibt es Blockierungen,
hat man mir erklärt und das hat dazu geführt, dass ich ohnmächtig wurde.
Okay.
Und seitdem ich aber jetzt den Schrittmacher habe, ist das in Ordnung, da ist das nie
wieder aufgetreten.
Okay, super.
Besuchen Sie auch Ihre Kardiologen regelmäßig, oder?
Kardiologen gehe ich einmal im Jahr und auch zur Kontrolle des Schrittmachers und der untersucht
mich dann auch, macht Belastungs-EKG und und und.
Okay, super.
Okay.
Ich habe noch ein Problem mit meinen Nieren.
In der Jugend habe ich häufig Nierenbeckenentzündungen gehabt und jetzt habe ich eine eingeschränkte Nierenfunktion.
Ich gehe auch regelmäßig zum Nephrologen und der Nephrologer sagt ja, das ist schon
sehr eingeschränkt, aber ich muss noch nicht jetzt irgendwie an die Dialyse.
Dialyse, okay.
Aber der Wert ist deutlich reduziert und das muss genau kontrolliert werden.
Also ich meine, die Nierenfunktion ist im Grenz, oder?
Ja, die Nierenfunktion ist reduziert.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Und seit wann haben Sie dieses Problem?
Ja, also bekannt ist das ungefähr seit fünf, sechs Jahren, dass die Werte angestiegen
sind und man sagt eben, man sieht einen Zusammenhang mit den Nierenbeckenentzündungen,
aber auch mit dem Zucker.
Ah, Zucker, okay.
Und wann war, wann war Ihre letzte Nierenbeckenentzündung?
Erinnern Sie sich?
Das ist jetzt schon einige Jahre her, das war in meiner Jugend, das ist bestimmt 20 Jahre her, 25 Jahre.
Okay, okay, okay, verstehe.
Und noch weitere Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Erkrankungen.
Okay, okay, was nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein, Frau?
Nur Insulin.
Nur Insulin, okay, okay.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich so zehn Jahre alt, wo ich am Blindhaben operiert.
Und vor einem Jahr wurden meine Augen gelasert, weil an der Netzhaut, an beiden Augen waren Schäden aufgetreten
und man sagt, das hängt mit dem Zucker zusammen.
Und mit der Laserung ist das besser geworden.
Ich kann auch wieder besser sehen, aber es ist nicht ganz 100%ig.
Aber ich muss da sehr regelmäßig kontrolliert werden.
Okay, verstehe, Frau Lewandowski, ja.
Außer diese Blinddam-Operation und diese Augenlese-Operation, haben Sie noch weitere Operationen?
Nein, keine Operationen.
Okay.
Und sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unfährtheitigkeiten bekannt, Frau Lewandowski?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Und jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit.
Frau Lewandowski, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Oh, super.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber sehr selten.
Vielleicht einmal im Monat ein Glas Wein auf einer Feier oder an Feiertagen oder Geburtstagen.
Da trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, aber das ist selten.
Selten, ja, ja.
Und wie ist Ihre Impfstatus? Sind Sie vollständig gegen sowohl die Impf-Stattu?
Ja, da liegt meine Hausärztin großen Wert drauf.
Sie sagt auch, wegen meinem Zucker brauche ich auch die Impfungen, die sonst nur ältere brauchen.
Also ich jetzt auch eine Grippeimpfung und Covid-Impfung.
Das sollte ich jetzt im Ende November machen.
Die Grippeimpfung und die Covid-Impfung, da habe ich schon einen Termin.
Und jetzt habe ich erstmal diese Schmerzen hier.
Ja, verstehe. Wie viele Mal sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Vier Mal.
Vier Mal, okay.
Und waren Sie in Nestersei im Ausland, Frau Lewandowski?
Ich war im Frühjahr, im April einmal für knapp zwei Wochen auf den kanarischen Inseln.
Aber sonst war ich nicht im Ausland.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Und besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen erst im Regelmäßig, Frau Lewandowski?
Ja, da habe ich jetzt auch aktuell ein Problem.
Das habe ich bemerkt.
Seit einigen Tagen habe ich einen Ausfluss aus der Scheide.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Das habe ich vorher nie gehabt.
Und das riecht auch nicht so sehr frisch, sehr angenehm.
Es riecht so ein bisschen, ja eher so ein bisschen faulig.
Und der Ausschluss ist so gelblich trübe.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Und deswegen wollte ich eigentlich jetzt auch zu der Frauenherz,
den wenn das nicht besser wird.
Das habe ich so seit, seit fünf Tagen bemerkt.
Seit fünf Tagen, okay.
Das ist auch sehr wichtige Informationen für mich, Frau Lewandowski.
Okay.
Und seit fünf Tagen haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Und die Ausfluss, der Ausfluss ist gelblich und trüb.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch einen Yukreis im Gentallbereich?
Nein.
Okay.
Und könnte es sein, dass die schwanger sind, Frau Lewandowski?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich, meine letzte Periode war vor drei Wochen.
Und mein Mann ist sterilisiert.
Ah, okay.
Und das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Okay.
Ja.
Also, Frau Lewandowski, jetzt möchte ich einfach fragen,
Sie, jeder Familiengeschichte, Leben,
jeder Eltern noch?
Ja.
Und mein Vater ist 74 Jahre alt.
Der hat hohen Blutdruck und Ur-Kolesterin-Werte.
Und er trägt auch einen Schrittmacher.
Und er hat in einigen Jahren allerdings mit so einem Elektroschocker
zum Defibrillator.
Und er hat auch schon, glaube ich, zwei, drei Mal ausgelöst.
Aber er kommt damit zurecht.
Das geht ihm ganz gut.
Super.
Okay.
Ja.
Meine Mutter, die ist auch 74 Jahre alt.
Die hatte vor drei Jahren einen Krebs am Gallengang.
Und das wurde operiert.
Das war ziemlich kompliziert.
Aber sie hat sich davon gut erholt.
Und im Augenblick sind die Untersuchungen soweit in Ordnung.
Super.
Eine gute Nachricht.
Ja.
Okay.
Und haben wir noch eine Schwester,
eine Schwester, die ist 44 Jahre alt.
Die hat entzündliches Gelenkräumer,
besonders an den Fingergelenken.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich verstehe.
Und Frau Lewandowski, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rechtsanwältin.
Rechtsanwältin.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Mal.
Aber es ist insgesamt stressiger,
das Familienleben zu organisieren,
Berufstätigkeit und neun Jahre Tochter mit der Schule und so.
Und das ist manchmal stressig.
Ja.
Aber das war bei Corona viel stressiger.
Das ist jetzt besser geworden.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Ja.
Haben Recht.
Also, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter, neun Jahre alt.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Okay.
Frau Lewandowski.
Ja, also meiner Seite habe ich alle wichtige Fragen.
Gestellt fällt Ihnen etwas ein,
das ich wissen sollte, Frau Lewandowski?
Ich glaube, das Wesentliche haben wir jetzt, glaube ich,
habe ich geschildert.
Was kann ich denn haben?
Was kann das sein?
Also, ja, Frau Lewandowski,
soll ich auch sie körperlich untersuchen
und einige Untersuchungen durchführen
und gegebenenfalls vielleicht eine Bauchutrasche
und dann werde ich durchführen.
Soweit alle davon der Vorliegen,
kann ich Ihnen genau sagen, was Ihnen fehlt,
Frau Lewandowski.
Okay.
Okay, das kann ich so machen.
Kann ich jetzt etwas essen, wenn ich Hunger habe?
Also, Frau Lewandowski,
wäre es besser, wenn Sie nicht etwas essen,
bis die Ergebnisse vorliegen.
Okay.
Okay, gut.
Prima.
Gut.
Dann haben Sie jetzt wieder die,
ich kann es 20 Minuten, aber einige Minuten Zeit,
sich davor vorzubereiten, denken Sie an die
Übersetzung Ihrer Patientensprache
im Fachbegriffe und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen,
das sind ja heute ziemlich viele,
haben vielleicht noch Fragen oder Ergänzungen
und da bitte ich Sie, diese zu stellen.
Wahrscheinlich ist schon alles gefragt worden,
alles geklärt worden.
Ich habe eine Frage, Frau Lewandowski.
Ja.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Gewichtsveränderung bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Haben Sie am Nacht einen Nachtschweiß?
Also, seitdem ich diese Bauchschmerzen habe,
besonders in der letzten Nacht,
da habe ich ziemlich stark geschwitzt,
aber ich glaube, das hängt mit dem Fieber zusammen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ob Ihr Schweißestuhl oder Teilstuhl in Ihrem Stuhlgang
in den letzten Tagen?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Der Stuhlgang war bis vorgestern,
bis vor Vorlagen,
weil der Stuhlgang über einen Ordnung.
Wind, haben Sie abgegeben oder?
Ja, aber nicht so viel.
Okay, Teilstahne, danke.
Ich komme sofort wieder.
Was meinen Sie, können wir starten
oder brauchen Sie noch Vorbereitung?
Also, 2 Minuten.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Verwaltung in Ihrem Bauch
oder in Ihrer Leise bemerkt?
Eine Schwellung, eine Verwaltung?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie erhöhte Atemfrequenz bemerkt
oder?
Also, dass Sie schneller atmen?
Ja, genau.
Nein, nein.
Okay, danke.
Ja, ich bin bereit.
Okay.
Guten Abend, Herr Roberts.
Ich habe gerade eine neue Patientin gesehen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Sie heißt Zwetna Nalewandowski.
Sie ist 41 Jahre alt.
Sie hat eine Schmerzengeläufer 74 kurs und 69 kg schwer.
Sie hat sich bei uns seit 2 Tagen bestehender,
zunehmender, bunfe, vorrender, linkseitiger Unterbauchschmerzen
und deflankend Schmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Patientin berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen plöstig aufgedattet sind
und sich im Verlauf verschlechtern hätten.
Und die Schmerzen legen auf der Schmerzskala
bei 8, bei 6 von 10.
Und die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Die Patientin berichtet auch,
dass sie seit 5 Tagen original ausgelöst haben.
Dieser Ausgelöst ist gelblich und pylp.
Ich unterbreche mal kurz.
Danke bisher.
Sie haben mir das gut geschildert.
Also ich habe verstanden,
dass die Patientin klagt seit 2 Tagen über zunehmende Abdominalschmerzen.
Sie haben gesagt im linken Unterbauchschmerzen.
Sagen Sie ruhig Abdominalschmerzen.
Und dann die Lokalisation linksumbilikal zum Beckenkammer reichend,
also mehr dem linken Unterbauch und Mittelbauch entsprechend.
Der Schmerz wird als dumpf und bohrend beschrieben auf einer Skala
von 0 bis 10 bei 6.
Hat die Patientin Druckschmerz, wenn sie drauf drückt,
oder andere Beobachtungen gemacht?
Also die Patientin berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen, wenn sie ihre Kniebeugen verschlechtern sich.
Nein, dann verbessert sich der Schmerz.
Ja, in Rücklage mit angezogenen oder flektierten Knie,
gibt es eine gewisse Linderung.
Was macht denn eine Verschlechterung?
Also wenn sie eine warme Fläche anwendet,
werden die Schmerzen schlechter.
Sie können vielleicht sagen Druck, Druck,
ja sie kann nicht auf der Seite liegen auf dem Bauch,
oder wenn sie drauf drückt, Druck und Wärme führen zu einer Verschlechterung.
Druck und Wärme führen zu einer Verschlechterung.
Und die Patientin hat beobachtet,
dass sie seit 5 Tagen einen Fluorgenitalis,
Fluor ist der Ausfluss,
das sollten Sie ruhig den Namen nennen, Fluorgenitalis.
Der Fluor wird als trüb, gelblich trüb beschrieben,
mit einem unangenehmen Geruch.
Fluor riecht etwas, man sagt auch Hötide,
Hötide, Fötor, ja?
Okay, ja, vielen Dank, bis hier.
Und was können Sie mir noch berichten?
Ja, Aspegleitsymptome,
neinten Ante die Patientin, nausea, Fieber,
38,5 und Nachtspreis, also Schweißausbrüche.
Ja, nausea ohne Emesis.
Ja, und Februar Temperaturen,
Februar Temperaturen bis 38,5,
haben Sie, wissen Sie, wo die Patientin gemessen hat?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ja, die Patientin hat oral gemessen.
Informatikbunden, ganz wichtig.
Sie berichtet auch, dass Sie seit 2 Tagen Obstibation haben.
Ja, oder zumindest keinen Stuhlgang seit 2 Tagen,
sonst hatte Sie regelmäßig Stuhlgang, ne?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und in der Vegetative Anamnese erwähnt Sie wegen Schmerzen,
wegen Schmerzen Schlafstuhlung habe
und Sie haben auch in Appetenz.
Ja, seitdem sie die Schmerzen hat, ja,
seit den Schmerzen, ja, okay.
Und am Vorerkrankungen leidet die Patientin
Diabetes Melitus Tip 1,
die ist ein bisschen in Sylin.
Seit Kinderheit hat sie Diabetes Melitus
und die Diabetes Melitus ist gut eingestellt.
Sie besucht ihr Endocrinologen regelmäßig.
Den Diabetologen, ja, Diabetologen, ja, Diabetologen regelmäßig.
Und seit 10 Jahren hat sie auch Pace Maker,
wegen Pest-Witmusstörung, Arhythmie.
Ja, wegen der Zustand nach 2-maliger Syncope.
Syncope.
Und außerdem hat sie seit 5 bis 6 Jahren
in Syfizienz, aber das ist nicht
Dialys benötigt.
Und warum hat sie diese Nieren in Syfizienz?
Ich denke wegen dieser Diabetes.
Sie hat Pielonephritis Attacke,
und wegen, vielleicht, Diabetes Melitus.
Okay, also wahrscheinlich,
sie leidet an einer noch kompensierten Nieren-Insuffizienz,
eventuell aufgrund von rezidiverenden Pielonephritiden
im Jugend, in der Jugend,
und im Zusammenhang wahrscheinlich mit einer
diabeteschen Nephropathie.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Also diese Sachen kommen im Betrag.
Gut, danke.
Ist die Patientin schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, mit Alter 10 Jahren,
im Alter 10 Jahren wurde die Patientin
wegen Appendizides operiert.
Also Appendizidium geführt.
Und vor einem Jahr wurde die Patientin
wegen Retinopathie, Lase-Operationen durchgeführt.
Ja, oder vor einem Jahr wurden beide Augen gelasert
wegen einer diabeteschen, wohl diabeteschen Retinopathie.
Ja, gut.
Die Schiplizenoidinsulin, sie nimmt keine Medikamente,
und Allergin- oder Unfältiglichkeiten sind nicht bekannt.
Sie raucht nicht.
Sie trinkt Einglaswein, einmal Promenade,
also sie trinkt eher selten Alkohol.
Die Impfstatus ist vollständig,
sie ist sowohl gegen Grippe als auch gegen Corona geimpft.
Und sie war im April 2 Wochen im kanarischen Insel gewesen.
Ich habe die Fragen nach Schwangeschafft verneint.
Und in der Familienanamnese gab es sich das,
die Vater an Arteelehypertony und Hypocholesthenomie leide.
Was hat der Vater noch?
Er hatte auch Pace-Maker.
Er hatte ebenfalls einen Pace-Maker oder Stetra.
Wie alt ist der Vater?
74.
Sagen Sie das ruhig immer dazu.
Der Vater ist 74 Jahre alt,
er leidet an Arteelehypertony, an Hypocholesthenomie
und direkt ebenfalls einen Schrittmacher oder Pace-Maker mit Defi.
Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter ist 74 Jahre alt und leidet an Kolangio-Karsinon Gelite.
Sie wurde deswegen operiert.
Und Sie hat auch eine Schwester, die 44 Jahre alt ist
und leidet an vomatrischen Atretis.
Sie ist rechtsanwaltend und hat eine gesunde Tochter.
Wie alt ist die Tochter?
Ich habe es gesagt, 9 Jahre.
Ich habe es gesagt, 9 Jahre alt.
Hallo.
Aufgrund der ananistischen Angaben gehe ich von einer Salpingitis aus.
Ja.
Okay.
Und die finanzielle Diagnostik kommen auch,
was noch, die Welttycholitis.
Und Pielonephritis vielleicht war.
Okay.
Also ich denke, die Verdachtdiagnose,
eine Salpingitis, Atnexitis liegt nahe aufgrund der Symptome.
Sie hat Entzündungszeichen.
Sie hat Bauchschmerzen in dem Bereich, in der Region.
Sie hat seit 5 Tagen einen Fluor, den sie nie hatte.
Der Fluor ist etwas auffällig, gelblich trüb für Tide.
Sie hat Fieber.
Und das spricht durchaus für eine, kann eine Salpingitis sein.
Da liegt daneben liegt eben das Kolon, links davon.
Und das Sigma.
Und natürlich kann dahinter auch eine Sigma, die Welttycholitis stecken.
Diese beiden Dinge denke ich, stehen vorrangig zur Abklärung.
Und natürlich muss man auch die Nieren-Situationen abklären.
Im Augenblick hat die Patientin eine unauffällige Mikzion.
Sie hat keine Mikzionsbeschwerden.
Aber trotzdem bei der Vorgeschichte muss man das natürlich auch mit in Betracht ziehen.
Sonst stimme ich Ihnen vollkommen zu.
Vorrangig verdacht auf Atnexitis Salpingitis.
Die Sigma, die Welttycholitis.
Gut, das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Und ich habe Sie gut verstanden.
Sie haben das sehr strukturiert dargestellt und auch gut strukturiert die Anamnese aufgebaut.
Denken Sie immer dran bei Frauen, ruhig nach der günnekologischen Anamnese zu fragen.
Sie haben dann lediglich gefragt, besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Frauenärztin.
Wenn das jetzt eine Patientin ist, die nicht so reflektiert ist, dann sagt sie, ja, besuche ich.
Aber sie berichtet ihn nicht von dem Flur.
Fragen Sie ruhig gezielt nach, haben Sie Beschwerden im Bereich des Genitales?
Haben Sie vielleicht Ausfluss oder ist die Periode regelmäßig?
Das sollten Sie schon erfragen.
Das würde die Sache dann noch perfekter machen.
Gut, ja, ansonsten aber, wann ist denn jetzt Ihre Prüfung?
Also 16. Dezember.
Ja, dann sollten Sie die Prüfung jetzt aber wirklich gut hinkriegen.
Da habe ich überhaupt kein schlechtes Gefühl.
Danke.
Gut.